ce sera une première historique dimanche
un avion de qantas décollera de los
angelès direction melbourne
un trajet de 13 mille kilomètres
propulsé en partie par de
l'agrocarburant ce sera le vol le moins
polluant de l'histoire à relier les
états unis et l'australie avant assure
le président des grilles somme à son
entreprise établie à gatineau a
développé une nouvelle semence à partir
de graines de moutarde éthiopienne le
karine à ta permet de produire de l'agro
carburant et de réduire de 80% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre des
avions qui l'utilisent
si tout se déroule comme prévu qantas
prévoit utiliser à moyen terme de
l'agrocarburant pour assurer plusieurs
de ses liaisons régulières
la directrice de cycle capital une
société d'investissement qui participent
au projet a de grandes ambitions on est
devant un cas de figure qui est beaucoup
moins évolué dans le temps
ok mais qui pourrait devenir aussi
impressionnante le canola dans les dix
quinze vingt prochaines années
surtout que contrairement à d'autres
semences utilisées pour produire des
agrocarburants la carie nhat hanh
entrepose en compétition avec la
production de céréales
il ne faut pas qu'on produise l'énergie
en utilisant des terres qui sont dédiés
nourrir les gens hors karina tas parce
qu'elle pousse à des moments où rien
d'autre pouces offrent cette possibilité
là pour féliciter l'idée le ministre
québécois de l'énergie crois même que
d'autres industries pourraient
bénéficier de cette innovation
voici ici une réalisation est
extrêmement concret faudra voir
maintenant s'il est possible d'étendre
la technologie à d'autres domaines du
transport
le nombre de passagers aérien devrait
doubler d'ici 2030 à l'échelle
internationale alors que les compagnies
aériennes se sont engagés à diminuer
leurs gaz à effet de serre
l'utilisation d'agrocarburants et
prometteuse mais pour l'instant seuls
les aéroports d'oslo et de los angelès
sont équipés pour offrir ce type de
ravitaillement ici vous la vallée radio
canada québec